we hope that the books will come out
ahead of the show but at the same time
George has this process and if it takes
him 20 years to finish the series that's
what did you take him I mean he's
writing to my mind the great epic of art
the great fantasy I think anyway of our
time so we can't rush him and I went one
of Russia and and at the same time we
can't put the show on hiatus you know
we've got all these actors wonderful
cast I mean I think the greatest cast
ever assembled for a television show and
we can't take a two-year break because
you know these guys are in demand and
they're gonna go off and do other stuff
so we have to kind of keep pushing
forward luckily we've been talking about
this with George for a long time ever
since we saw this could happen and we
know where things are heading so we'll
eventually basically meet up but pretty
much the same place where George is
going there might be a few deviations
along the route but but we're heading
towards the same destination I I kind of
wish there are some things that we
didn't have to spoil you know in terms
of for the books but we're kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place
so the show has to the show must go on
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Daenerys video I just added that
clip of Samwell and Jon Snow for context
I know there's a lot of questions about
to show changing things from the books
but it's just a good example that
they're all trying to get to the same
place so that kind of figures into some
of the predictions that I'm gonna make
as awesome as it is to see like the
really big WTF book moments happen on
screen it's also kind of fun to try and
figure out what they changed and why
they change stuff most of the time is
just in service of the cast that they
already have like you know they cast X
number of people pay them millions of
dollars in salary so sometimes that
means changing the book story to
accommodate that specific to Daenerys
story I think some of the changes that
they're going to make in season 5 are in
service of making it more interesting
visually really quick reminder to new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
it's an Amazon gift card in a couple
weeks whenever they start rolling it out
I'll change it and it'll be the HBO
subscription service so just general
spoiler warning for everything through
the season 4 finale I'll give an extra
special warning with a spoiler tag in
case it's necessary so here we go number
5 prediction Daenerys has dragons will
still be connected to her but they'll be
completely uncontrollable Daenerys
dragons are still bonded to her but
they're getting bigger and bigger
even though Vissarion and ragel are
chained up underneath the pyramid they
are super pissed and that is not gonna
change then we have to talk about drove
on he's kind of like off on his own if
you remember episode 1 from season 4
that that first scene with him when it
when it reveals how big he gets that's a
really good template yeah he's all nice
and puppy-dog in her lap but the minute
she tries to stop him from eating food
he snaps at her just imagine that
getting worse there isn't a hard and
fast rule about how big dragons can get
there isn't like an upper limit that
they can't go beyond it just depends on
how much they eat balerion the black
dread is always used as the benchmark
this is actually this is a picture of
him being ridden so you get an idea for
the scale looking at drogon in the
trailer he doesn't look a whole lot
bigger than he was in season 4 he was
already really big he is big enough to
be ridden you know maybe not by the
mountain even though that's a pretty
horrifying thought that would be better
be pretty crazy you guys can let me know
whether you agree or not but I feel like
in season 4 he was big enough for
Daenerys to ride him George RR Martin's
princess in the Queen short story covers
a lot of the science behind dragon
bonding so if you do have extra time
before episode 1 airs you should totally
check it out if
don't don't worry any of the big WTF
stuff that happens the show you know
might not explain it in explicit detail
but they do try to make it logical
enough to follow I know a lot of people
will argue that too like sometimes the
twists don't seem super logical but I
think that they do try to make them
illogical
so with two dragons going crazier in
season five mean mostly that they're
gonna tear up in a much bigger way
than they did in season four think like
what the next logical step is from
roasting goats and straight children
stepping it up to like roasting large
groups of people on to number four the
Second Battle of murine a scene in the
trailer the next battle of marine will
be a civil war between the slave owners
and Daenerys because episode 4 is titled
sons of the harpy and these masked
people are fighting unsullied I think
that they're the sons of the harpy
Daenerys this story is mostly confined
to book five and one of the big problems
I think the show had to address is that
it's largely political intrigue and
unless your name is Littlefinger
political intrigue is really hard to do
on screen in a visually interesting way
like it's not like Daenerys is gonna
move into a brothel so she can do all
the politicking around a bunch of naked
people that's why I think the show
whenever it's doing Daenerys storyline
is gonna lean much more heavily on the
conflict with the sons of the harpy
there's like this fine balance between
character moments like scenes inside
Daenerys throne room and big WTF action
moments like big battles that's where I
think the sons of the harpy come in this
kind of gets into South Park titties and
Dragons territory if you've never seen
the South Park game of Thrones episodes
you totally need to watch them before
season 5 starts it's probably one of the
best parodies of Game of Thrones ever
they can be kind of reductive in the way
they parodies Song of Ice and Fire stuff
but they are spot-on it's all titties
and dragon's boobs are like a metaphor
for the HBO sex factor the double
meaning with the Dragons joke is just
the ultra violence because Daenerys is
storyline is kind of stationary in book
five I think the show is just gonna
crank up the titties and dragons
metaphorically speaking maybe literally
two after season three I think there
were some comments from emilia clarke
about nudity clauses in her contract but
that remains to be seen I think it was
just that she wasn't gonna do like full
frontal anymore it didn't mean she
wasn't gonna do sex scenes so the easy
solution to making Daenerys storyline
more interesting in season 5 is doing
more crazy sons of the harpy stuff from
the books on to number three the show is
going to change the identity
the harpy from the books take this with
a grain of salt because officially
Martin hasn't revealed who the harpy is
I think the show is gonna make his dark
the harpy that just feels like a logical
WTF reveal for them to make given what
his storyline is in the books in the
actual books
I think the harpy is the green Grace a
female character but we haven't seen her
on the show yet and it doesn't look like
she was cast for season five that's all
just speculation there is this woman in
the trailer that mysteriously looks like
she's handing out blessings to a bunch
of slaves
it could be in volantis it could be
somewhere else she kind of looks like
Jessica hen wick who's playing Nymeria
sand but I don't think this is Dorne and
I don't think this is an i Marius and
this person is probably just one of the
minor female characters that they've
cast in the the volantis Braavos Marine
stuff that they haven't announced yet
that they haven't revealed there are a
couple minor female characters that they
haven't completely revealed yet like
where they are or what their names are
like I said his daughter harpy would
just be the logical WTF reveal for them
to make given what's going on in the
book so I'm just gonna put this spoiler
tag up so I can explain a little bit
better here we go the last couple of
seasons Daenerys has been courted by a
couple really big men his door is just
the latest in that line if she accepts
his proposal in season five it would be
a very easy slam-dunk for them to reveal
that he's the one leading the sons of
the harpy the insurgent force that's
trying to kick her out of murine the
betrayal plot would also fit
thematically with the mother Dragons
prophecy light three fires bride three
mounts face three betrayals
okay so book stuff over right now on the
show hizdahr is not a main character and
he's not listed as a main character for
season five but by attaching himself
more to Daenerys he could become a main
character in season six if he's still
around a really good example of this is
what happened with the Ramsay Bolton
character formerly Ramsay snow initially
he was a relatively minor character on
the show by attaching himself to the
reek storyline he became a really big
character now in season five in the
books it's a little more nebulous as to
like who the most important characters
are just the sheer amount of characters
is so much greater than what they have
on the show and the problem on the show
is is that the camera can only focus on
certain characters at certain times it's
just one of the unfortunate realities of
making television you can only fit so
many people in ten hours of television
on to number two
sir Jorah will fight his way back into
Daenerys
inner circle the last time we saw him he
being kicked out at the nurse's court we
don't really know where he is right now
we might see him in Episode one he
started out in season one is a spy for
Robert Baratheon over the course of that
first year he drank the kool-aid super
hard and started serving Daenerys in a
more earnest way whenever Barristan
found the pink letter I mean they did a
little bit differently on the show but
someone informed him that Jorah was
informing for the Baratheon's he tried
to explain what was going on but they
weren't having any of it they kicked him
out anyway
based on the trail of footage somehow he
ends up in the fighting pits as a
gladiator this is another big change
that I think they're got to make from
the books because Jorah is a lot more
mobile in the books like he travels a
lot more so I think that they're just
gonna simplify that and he'll wind up in
the fighting pits but I think that the
way he winds up in the fighting pits
will be very similar to what happens to
him in the books one of the big problems
in season five is that certain
characters wind up with Daenerys way
faster than they do in the books and
because all their plots are tied
together if you change what one of those
characters does you have to change what
all the other characters do too it's
just a butterfly effect
so make as many like Russell Crowe
gladiator jokes as you want but I feel
like it's gonna be kind of the same deal
with him somehow he'll get tied up in
the slave trade and get thrown in the
gladiator pits when they find out that
he's a badass fighter so people will try
to make money on him then based on what
he does in Dazz next pit he winds up
back in Daenerys his good graces but on
to my number one prediction Daenerys
will ride drogon it's the one big dragon
related thing that the show has not done
yet that would be a perfect WTF moment
what's more badass than Daenerys riding
a dragon maybe like a nice dragon but
that remains to be seen that's still a
myth really there's only so many things
you can do with dragons that the show
has not done yet I feel like putting her
on the back of a dragon would be a way
to address a lot of the chaos that's
going on in Mereen with the sons of the
harpy as we see in the trailer what
better way to make your enemies shut up
than to show them that you will roast
them with the dragon if they don't fall
in line the books have only just started
to address using Dragons and battle in a
historical sense like Aegon's conquest
the princess and the Queen but there was
this really awesome story from Aegon's
conquest that I think offers some info
about how Daenerys might use her dragons
in the future there was this one battle
where Aegon was going up against this
big force and instead of charge
into battle he just he sent his dragons
in to light the battlefield on fire the
entire battlefield instantly the other
army surrendered without a single sword
drawn sending dragons into battle is
like flipping the table in a card game
Daenerys hasn't learned how to do that
yet like she's used them but she doesn't
have really precise control of them I
feel like that's the direction we're
headed in season 6 like eventually she
will figure out how to use them in a
very controlled way right now drogon
kind of comes and goes as he pleases the
last time she used them to roast the
city it was more of a reflex
but I'd really like to see in season 6
it's her get to the point where she can
use them over long distances in really
calculated ways that's really I think
what its gonna take to rally everyone to
her cause like even her enemies and make
the Lords of Westeros start
their pants so here's my big question
for you guys how long do you think it's
gonna be before we see Daenerys use her
dragons in a really big battle the way
they're escalating things so quickly and
cutting out stuff from the books I feel
like we're gonna get big battle dragons
by season 6 quick sidenote - they
actually they just released episode
titles 4 5 6 & 7
episode 5 is called kill the boy episode
6 is unbowed unbent unbroken that's just
the motto from house Martell if you
haven't read the books and episode 7 is
called the gift my next bonus video is
probably gonna be another character
video so be sure to subscribe to get it
and if you have any requests feel free
to leave them in the comments which
actually reminds me congratulations to
Alexei Dominguez you win this week's
giveaway it's a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to message me on the on the back
end of my channel so I get your contact
info this is really weird exciting thing
that's gonna happen the weekend episode
1 premieres Marvel's daredevil is
dropping on Netflix the Friday before it
Game of Thrones episode 1 airs I haven't
figured out everything completely but
it's also the week of The Walking Dead
finale so there's gonna be a whole lot
of like special Game of Thrones
daredevil & Walking Dead stuff that week
so it's gonna be a lot of fun right now
in case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here to learn what HBO is planning
for Game of Thrones after season 6 and
you can click here to learn about the
first couple of episodes in season 5
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tonight
for Walking Dead
you